ich war damals ein adrenalin schub geben
ich habe die ganze welt gesehen ich habe
eigentlich alles mögliche erlebt und es
geht ich kann's nicht mehr toppen
hamburg im sommer 2020 das ist die
stimme von ronald million sie gehört zu
einem stier nackigen hünen dessen kurz
geraspelt des weißes haar einen
mächtigen schädel bedeckt aus dem helle
und sehr sehr schlaue augen heraus
blitzen seine kräftigen arme hatte vor
dem weit geöffneten hemd und dem
mächtigen bauch verschränkt ja wer ist
dieser mann mit boxer nase und dem
verschmitzten lachen vielleicht fällt ja
bei einigen der groschen wenn man seinen
szenen namen hört hier sitzt munter und
laut wie immer blacky manche nämlich den
könig und ich war kokain hinter in
deutschland viele sagen groß doch
eigentlich normal
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
monatelange miehling der schneekönig von
hamburg
rowling wird am 12 juli 1950 in hamburg
geboren die 70 jahre sieht man ihm kaum
an gut geraten würde man sagen aber
vielleicht hatte dieser mann schlichtweg
keine zeit zum altern dafür bietet das
leben einfach zu viel ich habe auch
jetzt ein alter erreicht und ruhiger
geworden bin meiner therapie gästen bis
runter gegangen ich bin jetzt seit vier
jahren knast ich habe in hamburg
versucht nach meiner entlassung wohnung
zu bekommen gab es nicht sie habe ich
nur blockieren da habe ich gemerkt dass
die polizei irgendwie bescheidet macht
tun den habe ich wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal auf die füße getreten den
modernen und in der nacht tragend und
hab ich gedacht da geht es nach bremen
oh ja den hatte auf die füße getreten
sie behalten ihn im auge aus gründen die
wir noch hinreichend erfahren werden
dabei hatte er in der eigenen familie
sogar gesetzeshüter denn sein vater max
ist polizist seine mutter else ist
hausfrau
1959 com thron als bruder ralf zur welt
die kinder wachsen behütet in einem
mehrfamilienhaus im stadtteil barmbek
auf die eltern versuchen ihnen alles zu
ermöglichen eigentlich beste
voraussetzungen für ein gradliniges
leben so schildert es jedenfalls die
2008 verstorbene elsen ii liegen in
einem interview von 2002 ich habe meine
kinder
wenn sie ein schüler kam sind wir immer
mal nach der auszählung und
habe mir kann man kennt ja nicht wie die
luft und gutes essen und liebe alles
fertig und auch glücklich schaut gern
zurück zu seinen jugendjahren aber
damals begann sich etwas in dem jungen
sportlichen anzuregen der vater später
1984 an krebs gestorben warnte sicher
schon mitte der siebziger dass sein sohn
andere vorstellungen vom leben hatte
also meine kindheit war sehr glücklich
weil meine mutter war zwar nicht
blockieren mein vater war einigte wurde
kohl hat immer gesagt guck mal wenn du
irgendwas macht er war er polizist wenn
du irgendwas macht er sich erwischen und
wesel cluster muss mit leben
ja der behütete familienalltag hängt den
jungen ronald mehligen 1 er wird raus
aus hamburg barmbek das konservative
leben hinter sich lassen was erleben
nicht dem mittelklasse wohlstands nie
verstecken
ich bin aufgewachsen in einer straße da
am britisch nur
polizisten gefängnis leute hatte jetzt
bedienstete überall wohnt man diebe
staatsbeschäftigte und wenn ich dann in
den 50er jahren gesehen habe wenn die am
sonntag dann ihre autos geputzt haben
und so dieser gelsenkirchener barock der
stadt und dieses meine frau im
pelzmantel deine hat noch kein main
august größer das ist mir so auf senke
kennt dann ist das doch nicht dein leben
sondern wann
so ergebe und hab ich gesagt
kriminalität hat er bereits und dann
habe ich das auch keine ahnung
eine konkrete entscheidung die aber noch
zeit brauchte um wirklichkeit zu werden
erst einmal führt blacky ein normales
teenagerleben mit moped mädchensport und
feiern er sieht gut aus und findet
schnell anschluss
eine der million besonders gut kennt ist
wolfgang gier sie sind damals 15 jahre
alt als er und ronald sich 1965
kennenlernen wolfgang ist schon damals
kam sportbegeistert und gilt noch heute
in deutschland als pionier der kickbox
und vielfalt sehne sie werden beste
freunde wolfgang gibt ihm den spitznamen
blacky weg seiner voll schwarzen haare
auf alten fotos sieht man ronald mehling
im judo anzug beim training pausieren
die langen gewellten haare wild ab
stehend und dazu noch einem flaumigen
pubertären schnauzer im teenager gesicht
[Musik]
wolfgang hier blättert in einem alten
fotoalbum und erinnert sich lächelnd
panischer typ kameradschaft irgendwie
dass die chemie stimmt gleich also bei
uns beiden würden viel zusammen erlebt
das zeug gemacht wir haben gelacht und
ja
das war einfach schön die fotos zeigen
die jugendlichen früher hätte man sie
vermutlich eher halb starken truppe
genannt in verkleidungen als bankräuber
oder in langer unterwäsche einfach so
als jux haben uns immer gegenseitig
eingezogen fotografiert er wollte aber
die lange unterhosen anziehen das weiß
ich noch so sind wir erst bahn gefahren
natürlich immer aber
die kumpels wolfgang und ronald sind
harte hunde und fotos beweisen sie
treiben ihren sport wo und wann immer es
geht da draußen
leider habe ich nicht mehr
bleibt wird zum draufgänger er bricht
gern die regel fährt zu schnell motorrad
schiebt sich in den vordergrund und hat
eine große klappe er jobbt hier und da
mit 18 jahren
1968 begeht er seine erste straftat
schwerere die tat stellt auch die
freundschaft zu freund wolfgang gier auf
eine harte probe
vier wochen
jugendarrest
diese schon heftig das sollte die
jugendlichen abschrecken irgendwas zu
machen und da ist das denn jeden dritten
tag gab es nun trocken brot da musste
die matratze herausgepickt werden ein
holzbrett und so das war nur eine stunde
freigang im kreis und man durfte sich
mit ihm unterhalten und als er da raus
kam da hat man schon so gemerkt dass da
gedacht hat so ich bin jetzt irgendwie
der der verbrecher oder so und dann aber
nachher wo das mit dem schlachter
gemacht hatte
da war ja schon die zahlen vorher schon
dass das doch schon erzielt hat nicht
direkte einzelheiten aber das forum dies
und das
[Musik]
am ersten mai
1978 wird der hamburger fleisch
großhändler manfred jährigen tot in
seinem haus im niedersächsischen
rheindorf aufgefunden der 45-jährige
erfolgreich unternehmer wird bei einem
vermuteten raubüberfall von mehreren
kugeln aus nächster nähe in kopf und
bauch getroffen die tatwaffe ein us
karabiner 30 m 2 die verdächtigen sind
noch flüchtig
gesucht wird nach einem betonbauer und
einem koch es sind ronald miehling und
sein freund hier ins w als sie den
unternehmer ausrauben wollen lösen sich
die tödlichen schüsse aus der alten welt
kriegswaffe
das grinsen auf mailings zerfurchten
gesicht verschwindet für einen moment
und die augen hören auf zu blitzen
das büro ich wirklich und das ist das
ist eigentlich das schwarze fleck auf
seiner seele ich bereue es uns gar
nichts aber das geholt
1980 wird blacky wegen fahrlässiger
tötung zu zehn jahren haft verurteilt
sein komplize jens w bekommt 15 jahre
wegen totschlags
der straftäter mehligen verliert dabei
mehr als seine freiheit blacky und sein
bester freund wolfgang gehen fortan
getrennte wege das verbrechen besiegelt
das endgültige ende ihrer jahrelangen
freundschaft wolfgang an ihnen diesen
tödlichen vorfall nicht verzeihen
ich komme schon wie hoch
das zuhören berufen worden was aber
sollte das höhere sein blacky arbeitet
im knast an seiner neuen karriere mit
knapp 40 jahren kommt er 1989 frei im
gefängnis hatte er enge kontakte zur
holländischen kokain mafia geknüpft sein
erstes drogengeschäft lässt nicht lange
auf sich warten als touristen getarnt
steigt am 10 august
1989 in ein flugzeug in seinem koffer
über 10.000 d mark
von hamburg aus geht es auf die 8000 191
km entfernte karibikinsel curacao die
kleine insel mit 200.000 einwohnern auf
höhe des weilers ist koloniales erbe und
gehört heute noch zur niederländischen
krone damals wie heute das
einkaufsparadies für koks
der erste gewinner der ecke riebel
gemacht habe das war so stümperhaft
lach ich heute immer noch darüber wir
sind darüber geflogen wir hatten zwar
ein kontakt den hab ich gestellt dass
wir was kauf konnten so eine narbe zwei
kilo ab sondern saßen wir im hotel die
zwei kinder lagen auf dem tisch und wir
haben mit ein bischen whisky gefeiert
und war haben schon den linden wieder
mal sagen den gewinnen gefeiert und
irgendwann davor kurz vorm abflug fielen
uns dann ein er müsse jetzt darüber
bringen das muss ja irgendwie auch wenn
nach deutschland sagt wir hatten gar
kein plan wir haben null plan so und
irgendwann sagte eine art pass auf ich
hoffe dass sie die sorgen seiner
schweizer sohn koffer
vor dem ersten transport wir mal
geschwitzt und er das im koffer da meist
geschwitzt auch wir wollen ja alle
besoffen deswegen haben was sich so
mitgekriegt so und wird durch durch den
ersten teil durch das war ein curacao da
sind versucht ruhig sondern dass mein
flieger aber in deutschland wurden wir
ja alle wieder nüchtern
und dann haben wir überlegt wie kriegen
wird jetzt durch ja nichts anderes
möglich als probieren und ging durch das
war ein riesiges gefühl man hat einfach
etwas an ja man hat etwas erreicht das
kann man nicht beschreiben als einfach
nur glücksgefühle
für seine ersten zwei kilo kokain hatte
blacky in der karibik 9000 d mark
bezahlt in deutschland verkaufte das
gramm für 80 d-mark an seine kunden pro
kilo machte über 50.000 d-mark gewinn
denn koks gilt damals noch als stoff für
insider und ist teuer seine kunden
stammen aus der hamburger heißes haiti
anfang der neunziger jahre die hatten
alle gilt die haben alle gearbeitet das
war alles so vor von ärzten über die
auch presse journalisten sowie duale
durch die dich wollen alle
rechtsanwälte die teilweise ich weiß
nicht was alles es gab immer cook schon
dass ich hatte das beste das heißt es
war ein das war sauber gehalten wir
mussten das gar nicht mehr schneiden
daher wir haben das einfach so raus
geholt haben
[Musik]
jetzt gilt lag in der szene als der
könig des kokains vom polizistensohn zu
hamburgs drogendealer nummer eins wow er
ist wer und niemand kann etwas beweisen
blacky vergrößert sein imperium schritt
für schritt jeder kokain transport aus
der karibik über der krise geplant er
lässt sogar spezielle koffer mit
doppeltem boden anfertigen so schafft er
es in kürzester zeit immer größere
mengen kokain nach deutschland zu
schmuggeln werden ja eine
fluggesellschaft machen können wir haben
so viel so viele plätze gehabt und so
für hotels gewählt mit kurieren wir
haben teilweise auf einen schlag 70 kilo
milch per flieger ich hatte jeden tag
und transporten können das feld kam und
war weg
ronald miehling macht millionen und
genießt sein leben in vollen zügen
endlich ist er aus der enge der
mittelklasse raus er kaufte sich teure
luxus limousinen logiert in swieten von
edelhotels und feiert ausschweifende
partys nur immer mit einem wachsamen
auge geregelt haben das krachen lassen
aber nicht nicht offen offiziell also
ich bin jetzt nicht losgelaufen habt ihr
euer prinz gemacht aber ich bin ihre
größte das habe im ausland gemacht
auch den behörden 4 black is gehobenen
lebensstil langsam aber sicher auf über
den schnellen erfolg und den raschen
aufstieg des schnee königs zeigten sich
selbst erfahrene drogen ermittler
anfangs überrascht auch die hamburger
zollfahnder beschäftigten sich damals
intensiv mit dem fall leckie mili soll
oberinspektor frank nießen erinnert sich
im büro des zoll hans auf dem monitor
vor ihm scrollen scans von
zeitungsausschnitten der damaligen
berichterstattung vorbei auf den bildern
hat black ich schon deutlich zugelegt
die haare sind nicht mehr ganz so
schwarz und die wangen deutlich voller
für hamburg hat erhalte eine rolle
gespielt er hat sich gut verkauft
persönlich gut verkauft in denen kreisen
wo kokain konsumiert wurde ich glaube
nicht auch nach dem was ich von den
älteren kollegen gehört habe die damals
gegen ihn ermittelt haben dass er eine
wirkliche größe gewesen ist der
kokainschmuggel damals war was ganz
anderes als heute damals war kokain als
solches noch gar nicht so
verbreitet kokain war ein anfang der
90er noch immer so eine schickimicki
droge die droge der reichen und schönen
aber nicht in der breiten masse so
vertreten damals haben wir noch sehr
viel mehr mit heroin und so weiter zu
tun gehabt mit haschisch marihuana
deswegen hat kokainspuren damals noch
gar nicht so sehr die rolle gespielt und
vor allen dingen nicht in den
größenordnung wie sie wollte
vorherrschen
[Musik]
kokain ist eine auf droge die meist über
die nase aufgenommen wird ihre wirkung
geht von euphorie über ein gefühl
gesteigerter leistungsfähigkeit hin zu
schlaff durst und appetitlosigkeit
beim abklingen kann es zu einer
depression dem crash kommen der sich nur
mit erneutem konsum beseitigen lässt
folgen exzessiven konsums sind psychosen
aggressivität paranoia und physische
schäden am herz kreislauf system und im
gehirn
hauptumschlagplatz der droge ist
südamerika hier wird das weiße pulver in
einem mehrstufigen produktionsverfahren
aus den blättern des koka strauß
gewonnen von kolumbien peru und bolivien
aus wird die droge in die ganze welt
exportiert in den ersten jahren des
kokain booms anfang der 80er jahre
nutzen die drogenhändler vor allem die
karibik als zwischenstation und
importieren ihre ware von hier aus
weiter nach nordamerika anfang der 90er
jahre decken die kartelle den
europäischen markt mit kokain zu
überschwemmen die südamerikanischen
drogenbarone wollen so ihre milliarden-
gewinne weiter ausbauen
gleichzeitig verstärken die usa ihre
kontrollen die fahnder beschlagnahmen
immer größere mengen kokain
die kartelle erschließen neue
handelsrouten mit europa einschließlich
deutschland finden sie schließlich einen
lukrativen markt bis heute zollfahnder
nielsen in hamburg kann die
größenordnungen nur schätzen wie viel
kokain wurde geschmuggelt es lässt sich
so nicht ganz einfach sagen ich kann als
person die ich im reiseführer eventuell
empfänger bin in meinen koffer was holen
und dann kann ich vielleicht sehen oder
auch 15 kilo schmuck habe ich aber einen
ganzen schiffscontainer voll mit ware
ist es eine ganz andere mengen da reden
wir heute aktuell von schmoren mengen
die bei 500 kilo liegen das kann
natürlich kein einzelner reisen
mitnehmen heute boomt der schmuggel und
handel mit kokain in europa und
deutschland lange schon ist das weiße
pulver keine luxus troge mehr
mittlerweile greifen menschen aus allen
sozialen schichten zum kokain
laut dem eu drogenbericht von 2009/10
konsumierten im gleichen jahr
schätzungsweise 43 millionen europäer
das rauschgift auch der zoll in hamburg
beschlagnahmt immer häufiger und immer
größere mengen an schmuggelware aus
südamerika der zoll hat letztes jahr
2009 10 fast zehn tonnen kokain
sichergestellt
in rotterdam und antwerpen waren die
zahlen noch um ein vielfaches größer
bremen im sommer 2020 voll gepackt mit
einkaufstüten kommt lucky in einer
eigens für heute an gemieteten
ferienwohnung an seine wohnung bleibt
privatsache ehefrau und tochter warten
schon eine weile und begrüßen den hünen
der macht sich aber gleich an herd und
spüle zu schaffen
die ferienwohnung hat eine große küche
und das ist was blacky braucht an der
langen tafel in der mitte des raumes
sitzen ines miehling und die 17 jährige
miriam die ein shirt mit der stickerei
real gangster der schneekönig trägt sie
ist sich bei stolz auf ihren vater und
gibt ihm einen kuss auf die wange
schön entspannt kochen dass die bilder
machen das ist schön entspannt
ihr müsst immer gekocht und dann kommt
es immer bei der wein und heben und
nicht alles morgen
seinen lebensmittelpunkt hat ronald
black bieling nun hier in bremen
gefunden miriam wuselt in der küche
herum und hilft ihrem vater beim kochen
die schülerin kennt die kriminelle
vergangenheit ihres vaters er hatte ihr
vor jahren behutsam von seinen
verbrechen berichtet was ich über die
kokain vergangenheit vom vater denke
dass er das alles so geschafft hat dass
er nicht weil sie nicht
ohne verletzung hat die jetzt jahre
später immer noch hat sondern dass er
mit 70 noch keinen rollator braucht noch
keine wahlen keinen lüfter nie um eine
treppe zu bekommen oder dass er das
jetzt alles noch schafft also ich glaube
und auch beim thema rauschgift kokain
wurde miriam nichts verheimlicht jenes
lange dunkle haare blaue augen und ein
feines lächeln und den mund stammt
ursprünglich aus medien in kolumbien
gelassen nimmt sie am mineralwasser
miriam weiß was kokain ist wie es wirkt
und was man da auch mit anstellen kann
und dass auch eine ganze menge geld
bringt und sie hat von anfang an gesagt
wir wissen meint da hat nichts mit zu
tun
vater und tochter steht am herd und
verfeinern die lauchsuppe mit lachs der
erste gang ich kann mir überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dass das marriott kokain im
freien wenn sie es will kann sie es ich
will dass ich würde sogar erlauben und
wenn es so wäre und sie wird mich fragen
und wird sagen kann zu mir was reine
soundso ja ich würde ich machen für
miriam sind drogen also kein thema das
essen ist deutlich wichtiger
[Musik]
für viele jugendliche aber sind kokain
und andere drogen ein wichtiger
bestandteil ihres lebens und ihres
selbstverständnisses als teenager von
seiner eigenen familie hält lage den
stoff unbedingt fern kokain zähne
deutschland gut tat sich viel geändert
wirklich sehr viel seit meiner das zeit
früher war das eigentlich so dass viele
deutsche das gemacht haben und das waren
alles kleine klubs die ihren bogen
zwischen gedealt haben heute ist es sehr
organisiert körper eigentlich hollande
warm und auf diese insel ging unheimlich
fehler das war ja noch zum kleinkrämerei
sehr viel arbeit für verhältnismäßig
wenig gewinnen die schönste zeit ist
einig gewesen wo sie gingen also das war
oktober fuhr zum ersten mal älter
schneekönig zugang zu den berüchtigten
drogenkartellen zu einer welt der
auftragsmorde der korruption und der
milliarden schweren deals
bogotá hauptstadt kolumbiens mit acht
millionen einwohnern liegt auf 2600
metern höhe inmitten der alten slum
artigen vorstädte wechseln sich mit
hochhäusern und kolonialbauten ab blacky
schaut sich mit zusammengekniffenen
augen seine selbst gefilmten altenheim
acht videoaufnahmen an die fahrt durch
die quirlige stadt das rumpeln über
schlechte straßen er erinnert sich die
berge und das licht bleibt die seufzt
und sofort blitzen seine augen wieder
auf der deal in kolumbien ganz anderer
wie der in kürze der kasache kaufst du
kleine mengen zu zehn kilo dann kommen
die leute ins hotel gefahren bring die
mit so einer hitze motelzimmer die wird
das liegt so hin und zahlst du das und
die koloniale da nicht sehr saubere
geschäftsleute und wenn du in diesen
klub drinne bis dann er postete gar
keine gedanken machen der jetzt sehr
gerade sehr gemütlich auch in besitz
einer familie gewürzt appetit mit müssen
erst und kaffee kuchen befährt der
entspannte atmosphäre cool das ist
geschichte jetzt will blacky bei den
großen jungs mitmachen und vom
beistelltisch an die tafel gebeten
werden ja geschäfte mit den großen
drogenkartellen eine nicht ungefährliche
angelegenheit bei den leuten die er
hinterher größenordnung arbeiten wird
der gibt's kein thema so warum wird da
gibts nur gerade untote in kolumbien
bereich eigentlich ständig bewaffnet
wenn ich ja zu höheren freundin bella
die kanone vorne gelassen
abgegeben aber ich forsche nicht
verfasst muss auch sein
kokain hochburg kolumbien seit anfang
der 80er jahre pop die produktion unter
handel mit der droge zwei der
bekanntesten und mächtigsten familien im
koks geschäft sind das kartell unter der
führung der brüder rodrigues oder
cuellar und das medellin kartell ihr
anführer der berüchtigte drogenboss
pablo escobar bis heute ist kolumbien
der größte kokainproduzent
laut dem drogenbericht der un von 2017
wurden dort fast 2000 tonnen der droge
hergestellt das entspricht 70 prozent
des gesamten welthandels tendenz
steigend die kartelle errichten dafür
drogen labore in den undurchdringlichen
dschungeln von südamerika hier
produzieren so genannte köche
tonnenweise reines kokain aus den
blättern des koka strauß das pulver wird
später in die usa aber auch weltweit
verschifft und findet seinen weg nach
hamburg
natürlich war etliche male ich habe auch
oft da eingekauft ich weiß nur zwei kilo
passte ergeben ein kilo kokain
ich sage mal 40 50 kilo blätter dann
daraus kriegt man die kilo passt es war
nur teilweise lustig die cousine rosa
sind die die köche die er wird die
nennen sie könnte die das machen die
schmecken mit den fingern ab die haben
das keine ahnung das sind die machen das
pressekorps ich habe das eigentlich
getestet wichtig mit der nase viele
testen habe der nase das habe ich
gemacht man kann das reiben zwischen den
fingern dann spürt man weiß es ist eine
stehen das muss die schnee schmilzt bei
den letzten worten reibt blacky die
fingerspitzen aneinander als würde ihn
wieder spüren den stoff der seine welt
war eine welt die nun dass höhere war
zudem sein alter freund wolfgang beer
ihn berufen fühlte
ortswechsel hamburger hafen blacky sitzt
bei bier und fischbrötchen auf der
aussichtsplattform und schaut dem
treiben auf dem wasser zu nun fällt sein
blick auf ein riesiges containerschiff
wenn man mich fragen nicht eingeführt
haben da werde ich das natürlich nicht
beantworten
ich kann dazu sagen ja es war ein
bisschen was ja wenn ich hier bin und
containerschiffe sich immer feuchte und
feuchte hände war mir mal große mein
geld bekomme
ronald miehling war und ist mit
sicherheit nicht der einzige der genau
dies moment feuchte hände bekommt neben
rotterdam und antwerpen zählt der
hamburger hafen heute als
hauptumschlagplatz für kokain in europa
experten vermuten dass hier jährlich
hunderte tonnen kokain in containern
versteckt werden doch das
zollfahndungsamt der hansestadt kennt
heute viele tricks der südamerikanischen
schmuggler alleine 2009 10 konnten die
ermittler bei kontrollen fast zehn
tonnen kokain sicherstellen viel aber
vermutlich ein tropfen auf dem heißen
stein
zurück zu zoll oder inspektor niesen
wieder ruft er auf seinem rechner fotos
von drogen funden auf kupfer tüten
katzenfutter säcke es gibt grundsätzlich
zwei arten drogen zu schmuggeln zwei
große verfahren haben die immer wieder
auftauchen das ist dieses drop off das
ist zb eine geschichte hinter als im
report verfahren dabei zeigte ein foto
von einem geöffneten container drinnen
viele sporttaschen und ein schicker
oldtimer das waren damals 190 kilogramm
die in diesen berühmten sporttaschen
direkt hinter der tür des containers
liegen legal ware waren zwei oldtimer vw
bus t1 modelle wir haben die türen
aufgemacht stand direkt vor den taschen
mit dem kokain dass es dieses jahr
gewesen das nächste foto zeigt dutzende
riesige wasserdichte rucksäcke hinter
einem stahl durchgang zu einem hohlraum
von wohnzimmer größe ein schiff wo wir
dann bei einer durchsuchung in einem
großen begehbaren teil des schornsteins
vom schiffe vom schiff hinter einem man
locker 500 kilo kokain gefunden haben
das war für das sogenannte drop auf
verfahren repariert das heißt die
seefest wasserfesten taschen sollten
über bord geschmissen werden das
wiederum bedeutet aber immer dass jemand
von der kuh auch involviert ist weil es
muss ja jemand an bord die taschen über
bord schmeißen jeder fund im hamburger
hafen wird vom zollfahndungsamt in
laboren akribisch geprüft und chemisch
analysiert so sammelt die behörde
wichtige erkenntnisse über qualität und
marktwert der drogen das kokain wie ist
aus südamerika kommt wenn es nicht
gestrecktes liegt bei 90 bis 95 prozent
reinheitsgehalt wir rechnen hier im
prinzip für hamburg mit um bei 50.000
euro für ein kilo
der hamburger zoll leistet seinen
beitrag denn laut dem aktuellen
drogenbericht der vereinten nationen
wurden im jahr 2017 weltweit 1200 75
tonnen kokain abgefangen
im vergleich zum vorjahr eine steigerung
um 13 prozent vermutlich fallen die
zahlen für 2020 noch höher aus
[Musik]
bogotá mitte der 90er blacky und partner
rumpeln mal wieder mit dem die fröhlich
durch die börsen tolle stadt sie pfeifen
den jungen frauen hinterher gleite ist
jetzt nicht mehr ganz so jung und
knackig aber er versprüht charme und
vitalität die vororte von bogotá sind
dann wenig später auf der fahrt nicht
mehr ganz so schick aus große
schlaglöcher wilde stromkabel
prostitution und drogenhandel
kolumbien wird black is zweiter heimat
verbringt dort nun mehrere monate im
jahr der 43 jährige pflegt seinen neuen
geschäftsbeziehungen sorgfältig und baut
ein perfekt strukturiertes netzwerk aus
ronald miehling befindet sich auf dem
höhepunkt seiner karriere und er
schaffte es in die streng abgeschotteten
kreise der kapelle aufgenommen zu werden
ich habe in chrom in der spitze ein paar
war dass es eher so ne
ehrbezeugung das so oder dass du ihr
boss pistner es gibt nicht nur pablo
escobar in kourou - gibt noch ganz
andere klubs ich hab aber nie getroffen
ich jetzt aber können
die kolumbianer machen blacky an angebot
er soll neue transportwege für die
kartelle ausprobieren von polen nach
deutschland
es geht um zwei tonnen koks blackies
anteil 250 kilo sein gewinn 15 millionen
d mark heute 75 millionen euro der pole
war so wir haben mit vier leuten
zusammen geschlossen also in kolumbien
das macht man oft dass man so und zum
pool macht jeder 500 kilo der weg ging
nach polen nach danzig und von danzig
aus solvent binnenschiff praktisch nach
deutschland gehen das war alles geregelt
und da ist eigentlich folgendes passiert
die haben was geklaut
die polen wollen auf eigene richtung
arbeiten sie fangen das kokain ab bevor
es nach deutschland verschifft werden
kann für blacky dem schneekönig eine
lebensgefährliche situation
platzt der polen deal gebe dass seinem
todesurteil gleich blacky wischt sich
über die weißen stoppelhaare auf seinem
kopf und sein blick verfinstert sich
region jahre gibt keine zweite chancen
sondern wenn du etwas gravierendes
gemacht hat dann reagieren die und das
allgemein bekannt die hängen die leute
an den füßen aufwand sondern baum und
dann werden die in schwung gebracht
schauen sie auf die und ich hatte vorhin
daher mit einer handfeuerwaffe betrifft
ja gar nicht dass sehr schwierigem
anzutreffen so auf 50 meter ball auf das
tor herrscht viel spaß da dieser nähere
teilweise
ja die kolumbianer sind außer sich vor
wut unter massiven drohungen fordern sie
von den dieben die sofortige herausgabe
der ware die polin willigen irgendwann
aus angst ein
gleich soll jetzt die erneute übergabe
organisieren er ist der mann für
schwierige situationen die kolumbianer
vertrauen nehmen doch der deal
entwickelt sich für den schneekönig zu
einem desaster
ich wollte ehrlich gar nicht in die nähe
von diesem kuchen kommen sondern auch
die uns die polen auf der straße keine
ahnung 30 uhr übergeben so das war für
mich schon chaotisch den transporteur
ins auto packen lassen und bin immer
dachte er steht ihm gefahren habe ich im
hotel abgesetzt
ihr bleibt hier macht gar nichts sondern
das einzige was ihr macht ihr besorgt
hier drei wagen kaufen sparten kraters
ein und dann danach der schmuggel
fahrzeug da stört den schlüssel stecken
auch parkplätze wieder schon geklaut
oder gestohlen bauen polen bauen die
nicht empfohlen das war ein plan sondern
bedienen nach deutscher gefahren und ich
habe sofort gemerkt die diesen trennen
uns und die frau von denen von denen
transporteure und ehrlich gesagt
nicht an rufen dich dies nicht dass und
dann passierte folgendes gerne
geburtstag
und sie nimmt das telefon ihr haus
telefon ruft ihn an der glückwunsch zum
geburtstag mein schatz sondern kannst
dir vorstellen dann knallte
polizeipräsidium den rekorden und dann
kam die böse der eingeflogen haben den
anderen britischen mit dem auto und den
kofferraum episch und dann haben sie
frisch natürlich gewusst weil sie mich
eine verbindung gesehen haben sondern
ich wusste ich jetzt bin ich als
nächster dran das geht also schief
miehling muss irgendwie handeln die
polizei nimmt sofort die drei kuriere in
polen fest eine von ihnen packt über
blacky und seine geschäfte mit den
kolumbianern aus der schneekönig kann
gerade noch so nach hamburg fliegen er
weiß dass er im visier der polizei steht
und jetzt rund um die uhr beschattet und
abgehört wird
ortswechsel hamburg blacky fährt mit
seinem unscheinbaren c-klasse bands auf
der alten fluchtroute beschauliche
wohngebiete lösen breitere straßen ab
wir sind jahre straße und ich muss sagen
ich habe wieder beschneide daneben weil
das war meine frucht strecke dann bin
ich wenn ich mich nicht täusche ja genau
hier abgebogen
natürlich nicht so lang wie heute
sondern schon mit schmackes
ich habe catcher im auto gehabt und
konnte ihr telefon abhören sie kreist
abgehört habe er verhört wenn sie sich
unbeobachtet fühlen wollten dann haben
sie gesagt dann gehen wir mal auf das
kleine das kleine war immer ein handy
und da was kommt sie in der zehner
zurück abgehört
wo ich da oben an der straße war habe
ich hab ich über ihre telefone gehört
wie den zugriff plan so soll boyle
zugriff habe ich gas gegeben und diese
ampel habe ich überquert bin ich aber
220 230 bin ich darüber gehobelt und
wenn man jetzt wenn man jetzt über diese
straße fährt diese stadt ist also ein
leichtes pop oper soll leichter hügel
und ich bin damals direkt über die
kreuzung geflogen das auto abgehoben
wenn man sich in der verhaftung
entziehen will dann kann man nicht
überlegen ob man verkehrsregeln einhält
und dann kann man auch nicht überlegen
wie gefährlich das ist da muss man gast
gehen
und wieder klappt dann klappt nicht und
wenn das nicht klappt ja gut an landet
vielleicht im rollstuhl in spexard da
war der schutzengel zu langsam
blacky hat glück kein unfall keine
anderen menschen kommen zu schaden und
er entkommt die flucht gelingt doch
bleibt ist noch lange nicht außer gefahr
er muss sich einen plan b überlegen nach
der flucht brauche ich noch zwei oder
drei monate er drei monate in hamburg
dann habe ich ein bisschen geld gekauft
oder bekommt von freund von mir das
schwimmen fahren lassen dass holland
stammt sodann
um von dort in die karibik geflogen
[Musik]
was er nicht ahnt deutsche zielfahnder
sind ihm auf den fersen observieren
nehmen auf dem flughafen von san antonio
in venezuela endet schließlich die
flucht des kokain königs lucky wird
festgenommen
oder nahm sie erst mal milch auf seine
wache gebracht und dann muss ich wäre
praktisch münchen lassen auf toilette
gehen weil ich dachte ich schmuggel
hatte meine koffer durchsucht drinnen
aber alles normal und dann habe ich
bestimmt telefoniert gemacht getan und
dann kommt irgendwann an und clubberer
wir hatten ein gebot für dich der die
akten angeguckt und und ok hätten
angebot wir holen dich herausbekommt in
die usa betrachten das als geld
christie's christines neue identität
darf nicht mehr nach europa zurück und
dafür musste natürlich dein wissen
preisgeben ein verlockendes angebot
blacky muss eine entscheidung treffen
ich habe darüber nachgedacht
was passiert dir wenn du das machst du
gehst darüber die pressen sich auf sie
setzen sich ein das bringt gar nichts
weil irgendwann fängt für eine kugel und
für was damit die dritte spieler
informationen haben so etwas passiert in
deutschland oder in deutschland 15 jahre
denn zwei drittel sind möglich für zehn
jahre und was auch mögliches fuhren
offene vollzug als das heißt acht jahre
knast maximal 108 jahre knast
eine harte entscheidung
statt in freiheit als v-mann für die us
drogenfahndung zu leben wählt blatt geht
das deutsche gefängnis zwölf jahre hat
der knastalltag aber von reue keine spur
war es die richtige entscheidung war es
die liebe zu seiner freundin oder die
liebe zu hamburg jedenfalls ist die jva
fuhlsbüttel in hamburg kurz santa fu
sein neues zuhause das schillernde leben
des schnee königs ist damit vorerst zu
ende und man nimmt sich den schneekönig
erst einmal richtig zur brust dem wird
man das geschäft schon austreiben
da hat man mich praktisch enisa hat grau
das heißt links und rechts sind nicht
belegt du hast der doppelte fenster du
hast
noch plastik funk wird er gar keine luft
rein schwitze ich da drin und du kannst
nicht mit einer gesprächen das heißt du
bist völlig isoliert eine freistunde
machten beamten
einkauf machst du alleine
duschen alleine alles allein das heißt
du wirst wieder mal geistig getötet also
habe ich praktisch mit man fernsehen
gesprochen und der fernseh war mein
unterhalten partner die isolationshaft
setzt lucky zu erhalten und die
schwarzen haare waren einmal nach zwei
jahren kommt er schließlich in den
normalen vollzug
morgens war aufstehen unglaublich 6 uhr
sodann wird auf geschenke hat
gefrühstückt die türen auf und abends um
halb acht sind die türen wieder
zugegangen aber was in der zwischenzeit
gemacht hat so konnten wir zu hause rum
laufen dass leute besuchen du konntest
du kannst du kannst sich frei bewegen
das war die freiheit hier im knast in
frei nach autos sicher und durch da wohl
so und ich musste mich hier wohlfühlen
weil anders wäre es nicht gegangen
für die hamburger behörden und frank
nielsen vom zoll war die verhaftung des
schnee königs ein erfolg das war schon
ein großer fall damals der damit
abgeschlossen wurde weil wir
damals schon in einem bereich mit
million gewesen sind der halt
organisiert kokain aus südamerika nach
deutschland gebracht hat da ging es ja
damals wirklich um 100 kilo das war für
damalige verhältnisse schon sehr sehr
viel im knast land blacky auch andere
kriminelle größten kennen er freundet
sich zum beispiel auch mit mike wappler
an alias milliarden mike ein bekannter
hamburger betrüger der sich durch
dubiose geschäfte millionen ergaunert
aber das ist nicht das geschäftsmodell
von ronald miehling er bleibt bei seinen
leisten die strukturen die in übersee
aufgebaut hat hält er für stabil ich
habe in kolumbien noch einen guten namen
und ich kann jederzeit darüber fahren
und ich würde immer sehr freundlich
empfangen werden immerhin hat er nie
jemanden vertiefen und so träumt blacky
auch während seiner haft in santa fu von
bogotá dort schmiedet der große pläne er
will wieder mit den kolumbianischen
kartelle ins geschäft kommen koste es
was es wolle
im dezember 2003 wird blacky der
mittlerweile 53 jahre alt ist vorzeitig
aus dem gefängnis entlassen
seine reststrafe ist auf bewährung
ausgesetzt doch statt sein leben nun neu
zu ordnen setzt er sich in den nächsten
flieger ziel kolumbien der nächste
millionen-deal wartet hatte damals schon
venture mit jemanden kann man sagen
würde ein kolumbianer der hat mich
gebeten seine truppe in amsterdam
praktisch eins in ordnung das heißt ja
einmal kunden die die ja immer noch
handel und wie die sich in europa
bewegen sollen also ich sollte die
britischen ort trainieren und dort wird
jetzt eine million dollar gegeben eine
million dollar ein recht guter lohn für
eine beratertätigkeit sollte man
annehmen aber seinen ruf als gewiefter
gauner weckt größere begehrlichkeiten
die großen kolumbianischen bosse wollen
dass blacky in ihrem land selbst als
schmuggler in erscheinung tritt und ich
vorher gar nicht vorgehabt was zu machen
das war überhaupt nicht geplant
also ein kleintransporter und ich hätte
das britisch
gemanagt dass das haus geholt wird und
jemand gleich gegeben und wird weg
gewesen dass das war dilettantisch
sturmgewehren auch der die ausführung
von dilettanten und ich habe versucht
das gehege von der backe zu kriegen aber
ich bin ehrlich vor weggekommen gut
künstler rechner wenn man er übers
zusagt muss halt blacky hatte sich in
seinem eigenen netz verfangen die
schlecht geplante aktion bleibt auch von
den deutschen behörden nicht unbemerkt
wieder sind sie plagge auf den fersen
beobachten jeden seiner schritte das
kokain geschäft des schnee königs wird -
protokolliert er kann sich kaum irgendwo
blicken lassen und muss alles aus der
ferne organisieren material und crew
sind diesmal auch nicht die erste wahl
und einer küche zwei leute die hab ich
ein weltmeer auftrag gehabt irgendwo
hinzufahren unter vorschriften warum
hast du dir gesagt nicht telefonieren
und wenn ihr daran kommt und die drücken
sich arbeitsklamotten antibiotika zum
ziel oder an haben und auf ein
bohrschiff raufgehen die brust bruders
ist und das rausholen und wenn ihr das
gefühl habe dass jemand durch
bescheidene worte oder lass das linke
hause sondern passierte folgendes ein
telefonat ja ich glaube wir werden
verfolgt
ja wir sind doch jetzt im hafen dieser
was in hafen ich habe mich von der
bürger schnell aber im hafen von
antwerpen platzt der deal die belgischen
drogenfahnder beschlagnahmen in einem
überseecontainer elf kilo kokain
blackies kuriere werden noch vor ort
festgenommen
im november 2005 knapp zwei jahre nach
seiner haftentlassung stürmen schwer
bewaffnete sek beamte wehlings wohnung
in hamburg und nehmen erneut fest
bremen blacky steht wieder am herd für
das boeuf stroganoff den zweiten gang
und das lieblingsessen der tochter
miriam ehefrau ines beobachtet ihn bei
seiner arbeit belustigt muss 100
miehling kurz auflachen das messer fährt
dabei das marmorieren fleisch diese
szene rische mal war der letzte
verhaftung da war das und schweinebraten
und ich war gerade dabei mit einer
fleischgabel und dem messer da eine
scheibe abzuschneiden gerade ein pieksen
und dann hat das mit geklopft wird er
damit
sind die polizisten gekommen wird und so
ein einsatzkommando und ich bin auf den
fluren und war natürlich ein staubiger
klopft dann schlug die tür auf und
liefert 456 weil ich weiß wie viel die
spreng da rein und da natürlich mit dem
messer und der fleischgabel aber ich war
ja zu hause und ich war in shorts und in
den t shirt und strengen direkt heraus
sagten reden sie die waffen bringen oder
eine kugel drauf hab gedacht ich jung
war cool und rentieren bestimmt keine
waffen und ich will man schon im rat
ansteigen
die ist da aber da ist bleibt cool
schickt euch nicht in die füsse desto
weniger gut und habe ich das weg gelegt
und dann haben sie mich halt mit alle
mann überwältigt war nicht ich stand da
und ja gut
bleibt ihr geht erneut ins gefängnis
diesmal für zehn jahre diese
inhaftierung ist für ihn besonders
bitter denn auch im privatleben des
königs hat sich einiges verändert
und hier sitzt die veränderung in
persona am küchentisch blacky und seine
langjährige freundin ines trafen sich
damals in seiner knast zeit schon seit
zwei jahren regelmäßig und dann kommt
bald tochter miriam zur welt
[Musik]
das hat es wohl von anfang an hat die
heute 60-jährige blackies kriminelle
karriere miterlebt bei seinen kokain
deals hat sie sich jedoch immer
rausgehalten blacky macht einen
zufriedenen eindruck perser viertes boot
stroganoff es gibt ein privates leben
des coni links das ist meins und das
geschäftliche da habe ich nichts zu
suchen gehabt und das wollte ich auch
nie tja und 2018 machen blacky und ines
ihre liebe endgültig offiziell und
heiraten man muss jemanden haben der
neue alle sind und das sind jeder
gelegenheit das heißt gucken ohne
mittelsäule so über die ganzen jahre
in ihren weg gemacht weil sie hatten so
lieben weg gemacht und ich haben den weg
gemacht das passte nicht um zu leben
aber jetzt im alter passwort darf ich
habe meinen kriminellen wenig abgelegt
berlin wählt also ich war mit allen
fällen und das wiso alte verbunden
aber nur spuren im leben machen
interessanten lassen
2016 zwei jahre vor der hochzeit kam
blacky frei insgesamt saß er 32
eineinhalb jahre lang fast die hälfte
seines lebens in deutschen gefängnissen
seine letzten haftjahre hatte in der jva
glasmoor in hamburg verbracht heute
wohnt der ehemalige schneekönig mit
seiner familie eher bürgerlich und
konservativ ein leben das er früher
verabscheute eine dreizimmerwohnung
stadthotels bieten 600 euro monatliche
rente statt bündel voller 100 euro
scheine vom schillernden gangster zum
braven familienvater aber bleibe sieht
das locker und es läuft gut für ihn ich
kriege aufstocker jährigen grundstock
die auf ja alle alle denken wo habe ich
noch millionen verstecke die alle
natürlich auch
[Musik]
ortswechsel hamburger hafen auch ohne
maggi das milliarden-geschäft mit kokain
boomt weiter alleine 2009 10 hat der
schmuggel mit dem weißen pulver einen
neuen rekordwert erreicht laut experten
liegt die weltweite nachfrage nach
kokain bei schätzungsweise etwa 900
tonnen pro jahr mehr als 18 millionen
menschen konsumieren regelmäßig das
weiße pulver so der aktuelle
drogenbericht vereinten nationen ronald
miehling schürzt die lippen und zuckt
mit den schultern die ganze welt ein
problem werden drogenprobleme und die
die ganze welt denkt wenn sie die
polizeimaßnahmen erhöhen dann irgendwann
gewinnt die partie am schon lange
verloren kokain zu legalisieren wird der
schlauste schritt in die politik machen
könne die gier nach profit ist groß nach
schätzungen von experten werden jährlich
90 milliarden us-dollar mit kokain
umgesetzt die internationalen
drogenkartelle wollen ihre gewinnmargen
weiter steigern dafür mindern sie die
qualität des kokains das ist nichts für
den schneekönig der unbewusst schon
wieder die fingerspitzen dran am bereit
und auch die großen schiffe im hafen
schaute ich habe damals noch immer über
90 prozent gehabt aber nicht nur eine
schlechte sorte hat er dort 88 gehabt
aber sonst meistens über 90 weit über 90
heute kann man sagen dass wir das gut
ist
85 meistens nur 75 dh der gewinn mittels
erhöhter
sind ab dem mitteldrittel denn tiere and
wohnungs mittel für hunde drin ich weiß
ich was da alles radstrecken also das
was du dazu dir nimmst das ist dass
schädlicher die jahrzehntelang knast
entbehrungen und familiäre
schicksalsschläge hat million aus seinen
fehlern gelernt
oder juckt ihn das schmutzige immer noch
geschmunzelt wie frage komme mir
einsteigen könne kann man ganz klaren ja
beantworten wenn
du kannst zb als verfahren kletterer als
einbrecher da mussten wir 30 aufhören
weil da bist du nicht mehr fit genug im
kokainhandel oder überhaupt drogen
handeln ist egal wie alt du bist du
musst die kontakte haben und du musst
den kopf haben und du musst du musst die
leute haben die ja krepieren kommt viel
zusammen das ganze machen vom rollstuhl
aus da war seine regierung sei
[Musik]
die werde ich bleiben
nächstes mal tauchen wir ein in die welt
der verbrecherclans mit ihrer geschichte
ihre nähmaschinen und ihre millionen
kues verpasse keine folge und abonnieren
tatort deutschland
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild produziert von den wakeboard
studios projektleitung lutz neumann und
simone terbrack produktion fabian
schaeffler und felix steht bleiben
bildredaktion christina frank schneider
und stefan netzeband sprecher skyteam